شكرا جمال كل هذه التطورات مشاهدينا
نتابعها في
النافذه نافذه التحليل العسكري لمجريات
حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه وفيها نستضيف
المحلل العسكري اللواء فايز الدويري
ونتابع ايضا اخر تطورات المشهد ميدانيا
على الخريطه التفاعليه مع الزميله سلام
خضر لكن الخطه العسكريه المرحله الثالثه
من المعركه البريه الاسرائيليه تدخل اذا
مرحلتها الثالثه العواج التي تحدثنا عنها
قبل قليل عن شكل هذه المرحله سنتابع مع
اللواء فايز لكن نعرج الان على مناطق
الاشتباك عبر الخارطه التفاعليه مع سلام
سلام شكرا زين اذا كما
اعلنت الاذاعه الاسرائيليه تقول قوات
الاحتلال ان الجيش الاسرائيلي على وشك ان
يبدا ما سماها المرحله الثالثه من عدوانه
على قطاع غزه ليس الجانب الاسرائيلي فقط
سمعنا اليوم احديث من واشنطن تتحدث عن انه
ان الاوان للانتقال الى مرحله جديده تختلف
شكل العمليات العسكريه فيها
الذي
تشمله المرحله الثالثه بشكل رئيسي هو
اقامه منطقه عازله وبدانا بالفعل في قطاع
غزه نرى اولى بوادر هذه المن المنطقه
العازله او ما قد يكون اولى بوادر المنطقه
العازله اليوم كان هناك قصف وتفجيرات
عنيفه في المناطق المحاذيه للشريط الحدودي
عند المناطق الشرقيه لقطاع غزه بموازاه
مدينه غزه وحي الشجاعيه سبقها يوم امس
تسجيل ايضا تفجيرات عنيفه جدا في بيت
حانون وايضا كان قد بدات عمليه التوغل
البري بتفجيرات مماثله عند اقصى شمال قطاع
غزه اليوم وصلت هذه التفجيرات عندما يعرف
بمعبر المنطار او معبر كارني وهو احد
المعابر التي كانت تربط بين قطاع غزه وبين
الاراضي الاسرائيليه لكنه خرج عن العمل
توقفت التفجيرات عند نقطه المنطار تقريبا
ما زلنا نتحدث عن المنطقه الشماليه جنوب
مدينه غزه ما الذي جرى بموازاه هذه
التفجيرات اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي اليوم
انه اعطى امرا لسكان عدد من المناطق جنوب
مدينه غزه بضروره اخلائها هذه المناطق
بالتحديد هي تشكل قوسا
تقريبا من الرشيد تمتد من الشاطئ يعني
شمال شارع الرشيد الى مخيم البريج قبل
السياج الحدودي الفاصل وطلب من السكان من
سكان هذه المناطق الجيش الاسرائيلي التوجه
الى دير البلح علما ان دير البلح هي منطقه
مستهدفه ويتم قصفها باستمرار بالطائرات
وايضا بالمدفعيه نفهم من هذه الصوره بان
الجيش الاسرائيلي واخذ بالاعتبار المنطقه
التي طلب اخلائها الجيش الاسرائيلي وصل
بتفجيرات الى معبر المنطار هذا هو معبر
المنطار الذي قلنا ان اخر تفجير لليوم وقع
تقريبا عند هذه المنطقه وبطلب الاخلاء
يمكن ان نرسم صوره تقول التالي بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي فعليا بدا يفرغ منطقه حدوديه
لانشاء منطقه عازله وهذه المنطقه بطبيعه
الحال الكثير من المناطق وليست جل الشريط
الحدودي هي مناطق سكنيه يريد الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان يقيم منطقه عازله تقريبا
تمتد الى بين ك ونص و 2 مكم من اقصى نقطه
في اقصى الشمال الغربي عند البحر المتوسط
وصولا الى جنوب قطاع غزه الى اقصى منطقه
جنوب قطاع غزه عند معبر رفح وهذه المنطقه
تمتد كما قلنا بين كيل وكيل مر بين كر
ونصف وكيل مترين علما ان جل مساحه او ال
عرض قطاع غزه يتراوح بين 6 كترات الى 12
كم اي ان المنطقه التي ستقدمها اسرائيل
بموجب ما تسميه المرحله الثالثه هي تقريبا
120 م ايضا المرحله الثالثه تتطلب تخفيف
قوات ال او تخفيف العمليات البريه وسحب
قوات الاحتياط ولكن قبل الدخول في هذه
المرحله لا يزال القتال داخل قطاع غزه
مستمرا عند اكثر من نقطه في خان يونس
اليوم كانت الاشتباكات قويه لم او بدا
يتوغل الجيش الاسرائيلي لكنه لم يسيطر
بالكامل على مدينه غزه حدود
التوغل لا تزال من عده محاور كتائب القسام
تقول انها تخوض معارك شرسه وضاره مع الجيش
الاسرائيلي في تلك المناطق وايضا تستهدف
سواء القوات ال
او التجمع للاليات في الزنه كان هناك
تجمعا للاليات وتم استهداف تلك المنطقه
واوقع
القسام خسائر كبيره بالعوده الى المناطق
الوسطى المنطقه الوسطى مخيم البريش كما
ذكرنا ودير البلح يتعرضان لقصف عنيف وهذه
المناطق لا يوجد فيها مستشفيات وهناك
توقعات بنزوح المزيد من السكان اليها
مدينه ينه غزه بالتحديد ايضا لازالت تشهد
عده تطورات هناك اشتباكات نعم هناك
اشتباكات في اكثر من نقطه ولكن ما حدث
اليوم ان الجيش الاسرائيلي نفذ انسحابات
من تل الهواء ودوار فلسطين ربما للالتفاف
الى المنطقه التي تحدثنا بها ولكن المرحله
الثالثه بها اكثر من خطوه على القوات
الاسرائيليه ان تقوم بها وللتعرف على
تفاصيل ه هذه المرحله نعود اليك ز شكرا لك
سلام على هذه التوضيحات على هذه الخارطه
ربما سنعرضها ايضا هذه الخارطه وتظل معنا
اللواء فايز الدويري نحن نتحدث عن اشياء
مختلفه وفق الاعلام الاسرائيلي طبعا نتحدث
اولا عن انتهاء العمليه
البريه في غضون اسابيع نتحدث عن تسريح
الاف من جنود الاحتياط ثم نتحدث عن ثكنات
عسكريه تقام في قباله المنطقه العازله
التي تحدثت عنها سلام ثم المنطقه العازله
طبيعه المناطق التي ستقدم وكيف تؤثر على
قطاع غزه فلنبدا من
الاعلانات الخاصه
ب سحب او انتهاء العمليه البريه اولا ما
هي الاسباب التي ادت الى اتخاذ هذا القرار
هناك جمله من الاسباب اول هذه الاسباب عدم
القدره على تحقيق الانجاز الرئيسي وهو
السيطره على قطاع غزه تحديدا الكتل او
المناطق المبنيه اثنين الضغوط الاقتصاديه
بسبب دعوه 300000 من الاحتياط ثلاث التغير
في في الشارع في الداخل الاسرائيلي
والتغير في المواقف الدوليه والمطال
والمطالبات
ب تخفيض سقف الهمجيه في القصف والاطار
الزمني للعمليه وبانه لا يمكن انه اعطاه
وقت مفتوح الان تحدثنا حتى قبل ان يتم هذا
الاعلان نتيجه قراءه للمشهد الميداني وكنا
نتوقع انه سيقوم با ايجاد منطقه عازله
المنطقه العازله قد تكون حتى اسوا مما
اشارت
اي نعم لماذا لانه هو يسيطر على سيسيطر
على تقريبا اذا اذا قيض له على عده مناطق
المنطقه الشماليه وعرضها متباين ما بين
الاثين ك الى 4 م المنطقه الشرقيه تتراوح
من زاويه بيت حنون 2 م وتنخفض في بعض
الحالات تصل في هذه نقطه متوسطه استثنائيه
انما المعدل العام بيت حانون تقع الخلف
منها اذا ذهبنا للشجاع بحدود 1300 متر لكن
اذا رفعنا الخارطه للاعلى حتى نوضح البقيه
لو سمحتي ا تحدثنا عن ما بعد
الشجاعيه الان ناتي الى منطقه جحر الديك
هذه منطقه رغم ما يجري فيها من معارك لاحظ
تعبر تعتبر منطقه فاصله ما بين الشمال
والجنوب وهذه كان فيها
اي مستوطنه نتساريم الان هذه المنطقه قد
تكون منطقه عازله ما بين الشمال والجنوب
كذلك وبالتالي تستمر الحركه جنوبا الى
منطقه شرق دير البلح وشرق خان يونس
وتمتد الى حدود رفح الشرقيه هذا ماذا يعني
يعني ان المساحه الاجماليه ق قد ترقى الى
ما يقارب نصف قطاع غزه هذه المنطقه هي
السله الغذائيه يعني اذا حرمت منها اذا
حرم منها ابناء غزه لا يوجد اصلا ما يمكن
ان يقيم الحياه ويبقي على الحياه الا ما
يدخله الاحتلال ل الا ما يبعثه يعني كانك
تضع انسان في في في غرفه الانعاش و تركب
له الدرب وتتحكم به لكن
السؤال انا ساحي هذا يعني هو يسميها
المرحله الثالثه انا اسميها اعاده التموضع
ليس اعاده انتشار اعاده تموضع سينشئ قواعد
له وفي هذه المناطق التي تشبه منطقه فراغ
سكاني لكن السؤال لكن سلام اشارت الى
منطقه الى
قوس في المنتصف اي في في في الوسط نعم هذا
انا ما اتحدث عنه يعني هل يمكن ان يبقى في
هذا القوز ام فقد يك عندما تحدثت عن منطقه
وادي غزه الجانب الجنوبي من وادي غزه هو
هو يلامس منطقه المخيمات النصيرات
وال لو سمحت هذا هذا القو هذا القو هذا
الى الشمال منه هذا هو وادي غزه الذي
اتحدث عنه هذا هو وادي هذا هو وادي غزه
والذي قلت لك ق قد يكون ضمن المنطقه
العازله مسافه بينيه بين القاطع الشمالي
والقاطع الاوسط والجنوبي وبالتالي يسيطر
على هذه المنطقه ولانه هذه كانت
فيها مستوطنه نتساريم هي احنا اذا اخذنا
المساحه الاجماليه قد تصل الى 150 كيلو
متر من اصل 262 سياخذ اكثر من نصف قطاع
غزه ك منطقه عازله ط سؤ هو الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي كانت معه غزه باكملها وخرج
منها وخرج منها ما الذي ست يحققه هذه
المنطقه العازله والثكنات التي سيقيمها
عند هذه المنطقه العازله انا يعني هذا
مشروع فاشل وستثبت الايام انه لن يستطيع
انشاها الان قد يعيد تموضع قواته مرحليا و
يدخل في مجال المفاوضات لكن لن يكون هناك
لا امن ولا استقرار ولن يستطيع البقاء الم
يقل اسحاق رابين يعني يتمنى ان ان يصحوا
صباحا ويجد غزه قد ابتلعها البحر من الذي
اجبر المستوطنين على اخلاء المستوطنات
اليس رائيل شارون هل نتنياهو اكثر شراسه
ودمويه من شارون واكثر تطرفا اذا هذه هي
اعتبرها اوراق ضغط سيت سيحاول تنفيذها من
اجل تحقيق مطالب اخرى وهي نزح سلاح حماس
الان هو لم يستطع ان يلحق الهزيمه بحماس
لن يستطع ان ينتزع سلاح حماس فما فشل في
تحقيقه عسكريا سيحاول ان يحققه من خلال
اعاده التموضع
والمقاربه العمليات الجديده بشن عمليات
مركزه من نقاط انطلاق تقع في داخل غزه
وليس في غلا في غز طيب هو يقول بحسب
الاعلام الاسرائيلي القناه الحديه ع
والثانيه والث ع بتفاصيل
مختلفه انه سينهي العمليه البريه في غضون
اسابيع هل هل يمكن ان يقيم هذه المنطقه في
غضون هذه الاسابيع قبل انتهى العمليه هذه
الان عمليه اعاده التموضع لا تاخذ اسابيع
الان هو سيبدا بتخفيف هذه القوات هو كما
قلت لك التخفيف لجمله اسباب اقتصاديه
وعسكريه هو فشل في تحقيق اهدافه هناك
معلومات عن تمرد لدى الوحدات الدنيا على
مستوى الكتائب واعلى خاصه في بعض المناطق
في منطقه الشجاعيه و ما ما يماثل الشجاعيه
يعني الجنود بداوا حتى يرفضوا الاوامر
للدخول الى المعركه لانه هو يواجه جحيم
وبالتالي هو يتدارك الامور لكن يريد ان
يظهر بمظهر المنتصر هو حقق التدمير في غزه
ولكن عسكريا لم يحقق شيء حتى اذا ما اعاد
تموضع هذه القوات ستكون يكون تموضع مؤقت
لن يكون تموضع دائما لانه لن يقوى على
ادامه هذا التموضع طيب طبعا هو يقول انه
قضى على مقدرات المقاومه في الشمال لكن
نحن نتحدث عن منطقه عازله بطول القطاع ا
ما الذي يجعله امنا في اقامه هذه المنطقه
طالما انه كما تفضلت لم يستطع ان يقضي على
المقاومه ق قبل قليل تم عرض لقطه ثنائيه
وكانت في بيت حانون في اس في في الزاويه
الشماليه الشرقيه يعني ال الفيلم الذي عرض
قبل قليل كان في بيت حانون بيت حانون وصل
اطراف بيت حانون الساعه الواحده من اليوم
الاول من العمليات البريه وبالتالي اذا
كانت بيت حانون غير امنه جحر الديك غير
امنه هل
ستكون مدينه غزه القديمه امنه هل ستكون
دير البلح امنه خان يونس امله لا يمكن لكن
هذه هي عمليه توظيف في المفردات من اجل
تحقيق نتائج هذا وقع سيفرض على المقاومه
سيناريوهات مختلفه استعداد مختلف الان
معركه المقاومه اصلا مبنيه على نظام
القواطع الجغرافيه وبالتالي الان مع هذا
التحول سيكون هناك تعديل على اجراء الخطه
الدفاعيه لانه ستكون النقاط التي هي محط
تركيز المقاومه نقاط تموضع هذه القوات
لهذا السبب كان هناك حديث بالامس عن ادخال
كتائب هندسه من اجل تدمير شبكه الانفاق
اين ستدمر هذا الانفاق قد يدمر اجزاء منها
داخل المناطق المبنيه لكن سيسعى في هذه
المناطق ان يقضي على شبكه الانفاق اشكرك
شكرا جزيلا اللواء فايز الدوير الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي